what's up guys bang bang it's lunch
money time well while she's trying to
get rich lessons
trying to get our lunch money right i'm
here with planet as she finally has a
black hoodie on
you just look normal we have lights we
have a camera
our entire team is here that helps us
with all the content stuff so they have
made it amazing
matt jordy caroline there's others that
may come at some point in the future
but until we get into all that don't
forget that block fly is the sponsor of
lunch money
you can go to blockbuy.com this is weird
because i can't see myself
nobody wants to see that spotify.com you
can earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can
sign up for their bitcoin rewards credit
card sorry we may be a little weird
today because
uh there's people walking around
everywhere it's awesome we're gonna get
them in the video here at the end
oh hello guys um guys
hello guys and gals and folks
investors are spreading over inflation a
number of u.s companies are saying they
are right to a growing list of
businesses are warning that supply chain
bottlenecks
increasing raw material costs and higher
labor
expenses are beginning to fight 3n
is worried william sonoma's worried
maker mattel is worried what is
happening
here's how it works this is the game the
politicians and the central banks tell
you don't worry about
inflation i promise you don't have to
worry just trust
us the government will save you and then
everyone who actually has like a real
job a real business and actually
operates in the economy is like
yo dude hey uh the prices are going up
like
lumber up a lot gas up a lot
wages like this is a bad situation
what's going on
and then the government's like don't
worry there's no inflation we're here to
save you we promise you that the
question isn't really that high
and then they're you're like yo dude
what's the official inflation number
and they're like you know if i should
really wait for my son
i promise it's gonna stay really low at
one point four percent
no yo dude did you see the gasoline and
lumber prices the ship going through the
roof
like you might as well call it a rocket
ship so guess what
they're lying everyone knows the
official inflation numbers they're not
real
all of the unofficial numbers are way
higher in low companies the people who
actually have to
operate in a real economy are telling
you prices are going up we're worried
about inflation but the government is
telling you don't worry so everything
will be all right
today i learned that the government has
a very high-pitched voice that only dogs
can hear
also you know why hold on this morning i
learned something
okay what just keep going wait and i
didn't attach that if you know you know
go ahead
oh my god i just heard that
you're so annoying we're cutting this
out no we're not
come on let's go we got things this
morning he sang
on against everybody's will tell them
you're
oh yeah i sing that's fine whatever i
have a great voice actually
a lot of uh variety to my pitch what is
the next topic
credit suisse and namura warned monday
of
significant hits to first quarter
results after they began exiting
positions with the large u.s hedge fund
that defaulted on margin calls last week
uh it's report it's been widely reported
that it's archaicos capital management
play stupid games win stupid prizes
no taylor swift stole it because she's a
snake everybody knows
taylor swift i will you are it's a
control it's a contrived
him it's a contrived public i watched
the documentary i saw her
she's up in there trying to say well if
i come out and i say this then people
will think that we're not going nowhere
i'll sing along to all the songs it's
cool i'm a taylor swift music fan
but let's not get crazy all i'm saying
is that if you play stupid games you win
stupid prizes if you're gonna go use all
this leverage whether you're a hedge
fund
or you're the guy out in china who had a
25 billion dollar net worth
starting last week and he ended the week
with a
zero that's right he lost 25 billion
dollars why
because my guy was leveraged with no
risk mitigation
you know what they say all you have to
do
is make sure you have no blow up risk
and that guy didn't listen
next okay so uh i like having the lights
here everyone's here plenty can't get
mad at me because i have coverage that's
great
they'll get mad um just wait till the
camera
you hear them snickering over there they
all know so
the house there's a housing boom and a
housing shortage somehow
both at the same time if you don't stop
for wannabe buyers the shortage of homes
on the market combined with a surge of
competition from other purchasers is
setting off
bidding wars all cash offers and no
end of sticker shock when they give you
free money you should go buy hard assets
and that's what these people are doing
is they literally like you know what we
should do we should just take all of
this free money that we created out of
thin air because we're
in charge of the money supply and we're
going to stuff it into the economy now
liquidity is going to go in all these
people and
they're going to turn around and say wow
if you're giving me the money for free
it must not be that valuable
i should probably convert it into a hard
asset so now all these people are
walking around they have liquidity and
they're like oh
i want a house and she wants a house and
ten other people want a house
and so we all go to the guy who's
selling the house and we say hey how
much is it and he's like you can buy
this house for 250
000 and i say wow i'm going to compete
against a ton of people you know what
i'm going to pay
260. then she says i'll pay 270.
somebody says 280 and somebody's like
well i'll pay all cash 15 day closing
at 300 and he's like sold to the idiot
who just gave me 300k
and that is what's happening in the
housing market because when you have
limited supply
and you have an increase in demand with
free money funding the whole thing
you get ridiculous markets visa said it
will allow the use of cryptocurrency usd
coin to settle transactions on its
payment network
the latest sign of growing acceptance of
digital currencies
yeah that's right the mainstream
financial industry
nope
lisa has launched the pilot program with
payment and crypto platform crypto.com
and plans to offer an option
the option two more partners later this
year what is going on with visa and usd
coin
well you just told us what's going on
what do you think about this
what you do a lot of giggling on the
show but you don't you're not sharing
your opinion
let me tell you what i think the usd
coin is a stable coin pegged to the u.s
currency
that's not your opinion what is your
opinion my opinion is peg it that's fine
[Music]
all right peggy say it all right
go ahead that's it that that's what's
your opinion oh no there's one
i wrote about this this morning go
subscribe to my
okay so this happened and it's already
free
because we recorded this game before
what is this suarez canal
suez suarez it's not suarez shout out
francis
if you know you know the mayor of miami
is not stuck in the canal
no he freed the canal he literally could
do anything he tweeted at the ship
and the ship is free so the suit there
was a ship
stuck in the suit a very big ship very
large ship it is now
free how do you like looking at the new
york times article that you're trying to
read
where 75 of the page is covered with pay
walls
and you're literally just reading the
headline so all i have is aided by the
moon and the tides the giant container
ship was
and there is no more the moon the moon
jumped in on this game
oh apparently the moon and the tides
helped oh interesting i'm pretty sure
that the moon didn't do too much here
but
anyway no because it pulls the you don't
know anything about science
so the ship is now what does it pull i
would love to hear this there's a tide
forward and then it brings the ship into
the ocean if the tide
goes forward that means that there's
more water underneath the ship or less
more yeah so wouldn't that just push it
further up because it's buoyant
no you're buoyant she doesn't know she
just got confused
okay guys
what just wait till the camera's off
okay
are we done here listen you're telling
me that they literally got one canal
where you can put a boat and if you
block it there's 400 million dollars a
minute or an hour or whatever it is that
gets
knocked off it's 20 21
cut another thing through the islands or
through the countries or whatever
get another canal what are we doing we
got one canal
and when you look when you literally
look at the canal by the way it's
ridiculous
the canal i could swim across it oh you
got all these big ships
passing each other in the night that's
what happens they pass each other
in the night in the night but i can swim
across it it ain't that big make it
bigger we dug the canal why don't we
just double it it's like when you're
driving on a two-lane road and you go
down at five years later
like whoops we realized there was too
much traffic and they made it a little
bit bigger
if they make them out they're just gonna
make bigger ships and they're still
gonna get stuck
just because you can when was the last
time somebody when was last time
somebody got stuck in the suarez canal
you're not stuck in the shower
that isn't true but that was a pretty
good joke
i'm done here okay it's ass lunch from
anytime
she's so proud of herself
like like tough okay
okay william taft who got stuck in the
bathtub
ask ellen in the comments below
stuff looking she doesn't know that a
bathtub in the shower still lily
lily c is asking hi pomp and paulina
what methods do you use each day to stay
organized
with your busy schedules do you use a
paper
do you use paper planners digital
calendars block scheduling etc
i personally use both two calendars one
for personal in my gmail one for
professional in my outlook
and then i also use the third um written
paper
planner for everything else that doesn't
sound too organized
he on the other hand is just not
organized yeah just i solved all your
problems just don't be organized
literally if you're not organized you
don't need any i don't need a planner i
don't need a calendar
i don't need a pen and paper i don't
need anything all i need
is twitter twitter has the solutions to
everything
mayor suarez he literally tweeted the
ship out of the way
i could tweet my way into organization
okay i won't tell them what how to get
in touch with you
no i don't there's only one way and
everyone that i know
knows it's moist time i don't know you
don't know moist
moist counter day 31 how do you know
it's day 31 because
the dates aren't i checked keep stanford
wrestling i already like this one
because that's what he has all right
moist says i let it slip
close this time but i still beat the
24-hour clock i swear
post pandemic is not technically leaving
the country but i want to go to hawaii
it's a perfect tropical paradise and it
will also give me an overseas experience
without leaving home
the united states also stanford
wrestling alone raised
12 million dollars and they still don't
get to keep their program that's on bs
the ncaa is a mafia fax
uh and also they should uh probably get
in trouble for racketeering because i'm
assuming somewhere in there there's some
problems
it's a legend though what is your
question for moist today why don't you
ask them a question
no actually you have bad questions i
have a question no no no
moist if you had if you had to go back
and you had to think about
uh what maybe you actually didn't you
weren't old enough for cd roms never
mind
let me reverse i'm sure he was old
enough he's 20
20 years did you have cd roms i had oh
my god
i had cassette tapes i was walking
around with my cassette tape
thing loser
[Laughter]
loser i had mp3s where she had cassette
tapes
loser listening to my mandy warm britain
no actually that was on a cd
though they were not on cassette tapes i
had cassette tapes though
yeah what were you listening to the
little mermaid
asked my mom wait are you talking
about vhs are we talking about like like
you don't do you know the difference
cause that tape is for listening vh tape
is for the vh tape
vhs tape is what it's for the movies
are you sure for my 101 donations in the
lion king
all right moist here's my question for
you
if you were in my position and you had
and you had for an afternoon
find peace but also make sure
that she was entertained happy
and uh was somewhere in miami
what restaurant museum location
attraction or beach
he's just trying to get ideas for
himself yes well
if he's gonna give me answers then give
me the answer to the real questions i
have
all right moist that's it for today guys
there's no other questions no
goodbye i want to introduce you guys to
somebody oh wait
here are the people who make this
possible yo what's up man
jordy hey what's up i got one thing to
say read the profile.com
wait i didn't even tell them to do that
but that was actually very expert that
was a first take and they just did a
little loop like that
that was actually very good it's much
better than my co-host we may need to
replace her
with somebody who actually knows matt
and jordan until then
shout them out on twitter long bitcoin
shirts with makers see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends